[Música]
las honras fúnebres de pelele
transcurrieron en Brasil con una
multitud de aficionados visitando su
ataúd el féretro del rey del fútbol
estará hasta este martes en el estadio
del Santos el club que lo descubrió y en
el que jugó la mayor parte de su vida
también este martes toma posesión la
nueva conformación del Congreso de los
Estados Unidos y con ello los
republicanos tomarán el control de la
cámara de representantes sin embargo se
complica la expiración del republicano
Kevin mccarthy de convertirse en el
próximo presidente de la cámara baja
el presidente de Venezuela Nicolás
Maduro denunció lo que denominó como
chantaje de la política exterior de
Estados Unidos pese a ello abogó por la
normalización de relaciones entre ambos
países esto luego que la asamblea
nacional disolviera el gobierno interino
de Juan guaidó
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos en Brasil el
estadio de Santos recibió a su mayor
estrella los restos del futbolista Pelé
estarán allí hasta este martes para que
sus seguidores puedan darle el último
adiós el recién posesionado presidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva confirmó que
asistirá al velorio Alba Santana tiene
los detalles en el siguiente informe
sólo a 2 de enero ya fue uno de los
autos más esperados del año el de los
restos de Pelé la leyenda brasileña del
fútbol que pasará 24 horas en el estadio
de fútbol de Santos para que sus
seguidores le puedan dar el último adiós
es un sentimiento de pérdida de un ídolo
para todos es un ídolo además de una
persona que elevó el nombre de Brasil en
todos los rincones
pero se va con una misión cumplida es un
ídolo nacional y mundial
las primeras horas del velatorio del
Astro además de miles de fans acudieron
figuras importantes desde varios
miembros de la Corte Suprema del país
que también quisieron despedirse hasta
el presidente de la FIFA Yani infantino
que acompañó a los familiares de la
Estrella en el Duelo y pidió que todos
los países le rindieran un pequeño
homenaje vamos a
a pedir a todas las federaciones en el
mundo entero 211 países que nombran un
estadio en cada país del mundo con el
nombre con el nombre de pelé porque creo
que los jóvenes en el mundo entero las
futuras generaciones tienen que saber
Y recordarse de quién era Pelé el
conocido como rey del fútbol que murió a
los 82 años a causa de un cáncer será
enterrado el martes en una ceremonia más
íntima pelea marcó la vida de miles de
Amantes del fútbol en Brasil y en todo
el mundo y siempre será recordado por su
yogo bonito también en Brasil Un día
después de su investidura Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva se reunió con los
principales líderes de América Latina y
de la Península ibérica una primera toma
de contacto que muestra la vuelta de la
principal economía latinoamericana al
liderazgo internacional más detalles en
el siguiente informe de lluís Muñoz
con la presidencia de Lula a una nueva
fase para la política exterior de
América Latina por lo que a su
investidura acudieron los principales
jefes de estado de la región con los que
Lula se reunió el martes con Gabriel
borics de chile hablaron de integración
latinoamericana con Gustavo Petro de
Colombia trataron un gran pacto
medioambiental y con Alberto Fernández
presidente de Argentina de Liderazgo
regional personalmente creo
que el presidente Lula
es un líder regional y que le va a dar
un impulso al América Latina muy
importante su presencia en Brasil es la
vuelta de Brasil a todos los foros
internacionales una nueva era de
relaciones internacionales que no se
limitan a América Latina también es
protagonista la Península ibérica con
encuentros entre Lula y el rey de España
y con el presidente de Portugal Marcelo
reveló de Sousa esperan que por fin se
firme el acuerdo entre la Unión Europea
y el mercosur tras décadas de
negociaciones el presidente Lula se ha
referido específicamente al acuerdo del
mercosur y él ya ha tomado el compromiso
de que va a ser igual que España uno de
los motores sí lo vemos más cerca la
principal economía de América Latina
vuelve a la izquierda un giro que han
experimentado las otras cuatro
principales potencias de la región dando
inicio a una nueva era después de años
de una política aislacionista llevada a
cabo por el ya expresidente Jair
bolsonaro
Vamos hasta Estados Unidos ya que este
martes toma posesión la nueva
conformación del Congreso y el partido
republicano tomará el control de la
cámara de representantes sin embargo A
pocas horas de la instalación aún hay
incertidumbre sobre quién será elegido
como presidente de este órgano Kevin
mccarthy quien fue nominado para liderar
la mayoría republicana no tiene
asegurada su aspiración previamente
hablamos con nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez que nos
contó Cuáles eran los proyectos clave
que se discutirán en este periodo
legislativo y como la mayoría
republicana afectará a la agenda
legislativa de Joe biden
Pues precisamente son los republicanos
los que en la cámara de representantes
pueden proponer leyes y en estas
concesiones o en esta simpatía que está
tratando de hacer macarthy con los
republicanos radicales pues ha dicho que
entre otras cosas va a considerar
pedirle la renuncia al secretario de
seguridad nacional por su política floja
en cuanto a temas migratorios dijo
también que va a abrir una investigación
al comité que Investiga lo que pasó el 6
de enero del 2021 en el asalto al
Capitolio por pues expuestos a
procedimientos mal hechos en esa
investigación y pues dijo también que va
a considerar los salarios de muchos
funcionarios del gobierno y la
desfinanciación de otras áreas que los
republicanos quieren que se dejen de
financiar en el gobierno nacional
a 17 subió la cifra de Muertos tras un
motín ocurrido en una cárcel de Ciudad
Juárez en la frontera norte Mexicana con
Estados Unidos con armas y carros
blindados un grupo de hombres atacó el
domingo la prisión Estatal al menos 10
guardias y siete reclusos murieron según
la fiscalía Estatal de Chihuahua otros
25 reclusos escaparon y 15 personas
resultaron heridas
siete personas fallecidas diez oficiales
de seguridad y custodia penitenciaria y
siete internos
también hay quince lesionados catorce
personas privadas de la libertad es
decir internos y un Custodio vamos a
Venezuela el presidente Nicolás Maduro
aseguró que su gobierno está listo para
restablecer las relaciones con Estados
Unidos sin embargo calificó como un sin
sentido la política de la Casa Blanca
hacia Caracas esto refiriéndose al apoyo
que Washington junto con otros cerca de
50 países han hecho al gobierno interino
que hasta hace unos días lideraba Juan
guaidó recordemos que el 30 de diciembre
la opositora asamblea nacional votó a
favor de disolver este gobierno interino
y se propuso a cambio crear comisión
encargada de administrar los activos
estatales de Venezuela en el exterior
que aún están en manos de la oposición
con Estados Unidos Norteamérica ellos
han estado
Lamentablemente atrapados en una
política sin sentido
sobre Venezuela
al apoyar instituciones inexistentes una
presidencia interina una asamblea de
Narnia Que ellos siguen apoyando
Venezuela está preparada totalmente
preparada para dar paso hacia un proceso
de normalización y regularización de
relaciones diplomáticas consulares
políticas con este gobierno en los
Estados Unidos y con los gobiernos que
puedan venir y en Bolivia cientos de
mujeres salieron a las calles de la
región de Santa Cruz la más extensa y
potente económicamente del país lo
hicieron para pedir la libertad del
gobernador Luis Fernando Camacho
detenido bajo acusación de terrorismo en
el proceso relacionado con la crisis
política de 2019 actualmente el opositor
cumple una medida de prisión preventiva
que se extenderá por cuatro meses las
manifestantes condenaron además el
exceso del uso de la fuerza por parte de
las autoridades durante las protestas
sociales
las mujeres concentradas para pedir a la
policía que
ceseme de atacar jóvenes nuestros
jóvenes tienen que Camacho nuestro
gobernador
vuelva a Santa Cruz que no esté de rey y
ahora ha aprendido por cuatro meses sin
justificación queremos sensibilizar y
queremos hacernos Escuchar Tenemos
muchos jóvenes que salen a protestar y
son agredidos por la policía que es
traída de toda Bolivia nosotros Somos un
pueblo de paz y queremos Paz queremos
trabajar pero en condiciones normales No
queremos una dictadura en este país
hasta aquí llega este repaso informativo
sigan conectados a France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]